E
EVIDENCE.
>> VERY GOOD POINT.
THANK YOU ALL, JAMIE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
EXCLUSIVE REPORTING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO BRING IN DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM CALIFORNIA,
AND JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE MEMBER
ZOE LOFGREN IN HER FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE WE LEARNED OF
THE ATTACK.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
BE WITH US TODAY.
WE HEARD FROM THE CAPITOL POLICE
LAUNCHING REVIEW ON PAUL PELOSI.
TOLD'S POLITICAL CLIMATE CALLS
FOR MORE RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF PHYSICAL
SECURITY FOR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
THIS PLAN WOULD INCLUDE AN
EMPHASIS ON ADDING REDUNDANCIES
TO THE MEASURES THAT ARE ALREADY
IN PLACE FOR CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERSHIP.
CAN YOU TAKE US INSIDE SOME O.
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW, MAYBE THAT YOU ARE
HAVING IS WITH SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES, THESE DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN LAWMAKERS CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR SAFETY AND THE
SAFETY OF THEIR FAMILIES.
>> I'LL JUST SAY, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET SAFER UNTIL WE CALL
OUT WHAT IS THE CAUSE OF THIS
POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
I NOTED THAT BOTH SPEAKER OF THE
HEAD OF THE RNC, RA NA
McDANIELS, AND KEVIN McCARTHY,
THE MINORITY LEADER EXPRESSED
SADNESS FOR PAUL PELOSI BUT THEN
WENT ON TO SAY IT'S REALLY A
PRODUCT OF, YOU KNOW, CRIME
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATS FALL.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING LEE HARVEY
OSWALD WAS CONNECTED WITH CRIME
IN DALLAS OR JOHN WILKES BOOTH
WAS A RESULT OF A CRIME PROBLEM
AT FORD THEATER.
NOT ONLY IS IT RIDICULOUS, IT'S
PART OF THE PROBLEM OF
DISMISSING WHAT IS CAUSING THIS
VIOLENCE.
YOU KNOW, WHEN THE SHOOTING
OCCURRED OF THE BASEBALL
PLAYERS, BOTH SPEAKER RYAN AND
THEN MINORITY LEADER NANCY
PELOSI CONVENED TO CONDEMN IT,
AND BOTH SAID THE RHETORIC HAS
TO COME DOWN.
BUT I WOULD NOTE THERE WAS NEVER
A CAMPAIGN OF ADS TO PUT, YOU
KNOW, MR. SCALISE'S PICTURE IN A
TARGET FOR TARGET PRACTICE AND
POLITICAL ADS.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
SPENT TO DEMONIZE NANCY PELOSI
AND OTHERS, AND THAT IS PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, VOTERS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ARE NORMAL PEOPLE FOR
THE MOST PART, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS, THEY MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS ON HOW TO
ATTRACT A PROBLEM BUT THEY ARE
NOT IN FAVOR OF OUR COUNTRY
DEVOLVING INTO A CESSPOOL OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE, AND SO I DO
THINK THAT ONE DAY FROM TODAY,
VOTERS NEED TO DO A VERY SOBER
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT KIND OF
COUNTRY DO THEY WANT TO HAVE IN
THE FUTURE.
I NOTE THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WENT ON THE RADIO AND WAS
ENGAGING IN, AND SOMEHOW THIS
WAS AN INSIDE JOB.
THIS HAS TO BE CONFRONTED AND NO
LEVELS OF SECURITY WILL BE
SUFFICIENT UNLESS WE RESCUE OUR
DEMOCRACY, OUR DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC FROM THOSE WHO ARE
ESSENTIALLY ENCOURAGING THIS
VIOLENCE THROUGH THEIR RHETORIC.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY INTEND FOR
THE ASSASSINATION OF NANCY
PELOSI, BUT THEIR RHETORIC.
>> HAVE YOU SPOKEN DIRECTLY TO
REPUBLICANS ABOUT THIS?
>> I HAVE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH SOME, BUT REALLY, IT COMES
FROM THE LEADERSHIP.
THEIR RHETORIC DOESN'T REFLECT
THEIR NORMAL VOTERS.
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW,
REPUBLICAN VOTERS CITIZENS HAVE
SENT PEOPLE WHO ARE RECKLESS TO
THE CAPITAL TO REPRESENT THEM.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A COURSE
CORRECTION.
>> I DO WANT TO SHIFT TO THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK, THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
THE VICE CHAIR LIZ CHENEY SAYS
THE PANEL IS IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEYS ABOUT TESTIFYING UNDER
OATH.
SHE ALSO SAID THIS ISN'T A
SITUATION WHERE THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE AT THE QUOTE MERCY OF
DONALD TRUMP.
HOW DO YOU PLAN TO KEEP THIS
PRODUCTIVE AND UNDER CONTROL?
>> WELL, RIGHT NOW, THERE'S A
DISCUSSION.
I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY OCCURRING
AS WE SPEAK BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS AND THE
COMMITTEE LAWYERS.
HE HAS A DEADLINE OF FRIDAY TO
PRODUCE A BUNCH OF DOCUMENTS,
AND SO WHETHER THEY'RE SERIOUS
ABOUT HAVING HIM PROCEED OR NOT,
WE'LL FIND OUT.
HE HAS AN OBLIGATION, A LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO COME IN AND AS MS.
CHENEY SAID, I THINK A FEW DAYS
AGO, WE HAVE NO INTENTION OF
LETTING THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TURN THIS INTO SOME CIRCUS.
IT WILL BE SERIOUS, DETAILED,
UNDER OATH, AND COULD GO ON
MULTIPLE DAYS.
>> WE WANT TO KNOW OF COURSE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING, IF THE COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER HEARING.
CNN JUST LEARNED THAT THE SECRET
SERVICE SPOKESMAN SPOKE TO THE
COMMITTEE ON MONDAY.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER HEARING, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT YOU
FOUND THERE?
>> WELL, WE HAVE ONGOING
INTERVIEWS WITH SECRET SERVICE
MEMBERS.
I WAS PRESENT VIRTUALLY FOR THE
ONE ON MONDAY.
WE ARE WRITING A REPORT AS WE
SPEAK.
WE HAVEN'T RULED OUT REVEALING
INFORMATION IN A PUBLIC HEARING
FORMAT, BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
ISSUE A WRITTEN REPORT AS WELL
AS A MULTIMEDIA REPORT.
SO WE'LL GET ALL THE INFORMATION
OUT.
>> ANYTHING PIVOTAL FROM THAT
INTERVIEW?
>> WELL, AS YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT
PERMITTED TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
THE ISSUES, BUT LET ME JUST SAY
THAT WE WENT THROUGH MORE THAN A
MILLION DOCUMENTS FROM THE
SECRET SERVICE, AND SOME OF THE
PUBLIC STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE
DON'T MATCH UP WITH THE
DOCUMENTS WE RECEIVED, AND SO WE
HAVE QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT ALLEGING
ANYTHING.
WE'RE JU